Okay.
Chuck Norris facts you may not like.
Now, let me put things in perspective.
We have to be careful
when asked the question
whether we think someone is saved or
not. Why?
Cuz that is the arrogance of
presumption. What do I mean?
To
question or comment on someone's
salvation
arrogates to ourselves the prerogative
of God and arrogantly assumes that we're
the ones who are saved and have the
truth and aren't deceived
because we think
that we're
true followers who have the true gospel.
This is arrogance.
No one thinks that he's a heretic. They
always think the other person's a
heretic. So, we have to be very careful.
Now, that is different when you see
clear signs
of heresy,
clear signs of someone who's not a
Christian,
damnable heresy. That's different. For
example, Mormons, Jehovah's Witnesses,
clear. Or if someone names the name of
Christ but does something so scandalous
and erroneous that you know
that they are wolves. That's different
when you have those signs. But when
someone
lives
to the best of their ability a morally
upright life and acknowledge and worship
the same God, the triune God, be careful
in assuming just because they're not
Catholic or Orthodox they're not saved.
And be careful in assuming that you're
saved.
And I have to remind myself. I pray I am
and I pray God isn't hand me over and is
not disgusted with me.
Because I have a lot of reasons for God
to be disgusted with me.
Now, let's talk about Chuck Norris.
First of all, let's put things in
perspective. I did something on Bruce
Lee,
so let me now repeat. May the Lord Jesus
destroy
any idolatrous fascination I have with
Bruce Lee. May set me free.
So, let's state facts about Bruce Lee.
Let's state facts about Bruce Lee.
Number one,
Bruce Lee was an immoral adulterer.
Let's state facts, okay?
He was a womanizer, adulterer. He was
not an exemplary human being.
Number two, he died
in his mistress's apartment
making out with her and doing drugs,
shaming his family.
Facts.
Number three, in the last several years
of Bruce Lee's life, he became a coke
addict.
The Bruce Lee drug letters were released
where he was buying cocaine from one of
his students, Bob Baker.
Bob Baker was a Bruce Lee student in
Oakland, California,
and he's the one who played
Bruce Lee's nemesis in Fist of Fury,
Chinese Connection, Petrov, the Russian.
That was Bruce Lee's student. And he
would come to
he would come to Hong Kong to bring
Bruce Lee drugs. He would sell him
cocaine
as well as marijuana.
And
it became public knowledge several years
ago
when Bob Baker's family sold the letters
that Bruce Lee sent him.
They auctioned it and made a fortune.
And those letters became public, and so
now you can find it on YouTube, the
Bruce Lee drug letters.
Very damaging
testimony showing that he was a drug
addict.
Cocaine,
marijuana, and it seems like his wife
joined him.
So, he died a miserable failure and a
sad excuse of a moral example.
It's just a fact.
Okay? Here it is, Bruce Lee drug
letters.
And one of the most detailed
is right here.
Golden Ball training, very fair and
balanced.
And
the kung fu genius. The letters are
there.
Okay?
Everyone got it?
You got it there? So, Bruce Lee was no
moral example.
He was a failure.
And Bruce Lee
was not a fighter, meaning he didn't
care to fight in competition. So, if you
define fighter as someone with a record,
Bruce Lee said, "I'm not a fighter."
But Chuck Norris was a fake. Chuck
Norris was not a fighter, either. And
I'm going to bring you receipts. I'm
going to document and destroy the lies.
And I'm going to show you Chuck Norris
actually campaigned for Netanyahu or
Satan Satan Yahoo.
So, we're going to give you receipts,
okay?
But first of all,
the sad thing about Chuck Norris,
he was converted to Christian Zionism.
So, he became an evangelical Christian,
returning to his Christian roots, cuz he
was raised in a Christian home.
But the version of Christianity
was Christian Zionism. And so, he became
a shell for Netanyahu or Satan Satan
Yahoo.
Let me give you the receipts. You ready?
This is Chuck Norris.
Watch.
Don't be fooled by Jeremy Bird and B15.
They're not your friend. Don't fall for
their propaganda.
Vote with your heart.
Vote for Bibi. Vote for Bibi. You may
think he was great at point sparring,
you know, maybe in your dreams.
You could be great at point sparring,
and you suck.
And I'm not trying to hate. He was
overrated. And I'm going to play Rickson
Gracie telling you
he was good enough, but he not on a
level of a champion jiu-jitsu
practitioner.
People said nice things about Chuck
Norris cuz he's a nice guy.
They didn't want to offend him by saying
the truth. He was overrated. He was not
a
fighter and Chuck Norris admitted he's
never been in a street fight in his
life. He's admitted it. Don't take my
word for it. He's admitted he's never
been in an actual street fight.
Bruce Lee was a street fighter.
And I'm going to show you the receipts.
Come on, give you receipts.
So only God knows whether he could fight
in the street. Nobody seen it and he
said he never had a street fight.
Listen to him again. What did he say
about Netanyahu?
Don't be fooled by Jeremy Byrd and V15.
They're not your friend. Don't fall for
their propaganda.
Vote with your heart.
Vote for Bibi.
There you go. Don't be fooled. Okay, now
watch. That's not only time.
Watch here again. We come with receipts.
I'm going to show you what Hickson said
about Chuck Norris. Here it is.
This is from Chuck Norris' YouTube
channel.
I'm Chuck Norris.
Now
pray I don't get flagged because
copyright law allows for fair use of
excerpts.
If they do flag me, it's on Rumble. So
if I have to remove this
I hope not so I don't get a strike.
It will be on Rumble unedited.
So listen again.
Well, it's not clear what
Okay, let's go here.
You're going to get me flagged.
I watched Prime Minister Netanyahu's
speech before Congress
and saw a man who loves his country with
all his heart and soul. I ask you to
vote for Prime Minister Netanyahu.
The clip I played was from him. That's
as loud as it gets. So, now I have to go
to CBS. If I get flagged because of it,
I'm going to block three quarters of
you.
Okay.
I watched Prime Minister Netanyahu speak
before Congress
and saw a man who loves his country with
all his heart and soul. I ask you to
vote for Prime Minister Netanyahu on
election day.
The former Okay.
No, yeah. He look, he met Netanyahu.
There you go.
Israel PM
Gideon excited that he met
Netanyahu with his wife.
And then what does Netanyahu say? All
right, we don't need the security. Like
Chuck and now we got Chuck Norris. We
don't need
the security. Yeah, he even went to the
Wailing Wall.
Minister, good to see you. Oh, thank
you. Listen, Israel was strong, but it's
indestructible now.
Uh-huh, Israel is strong, but now it's
indestructible.
THAT'S CHUCK NORRIS FOR YOU GUYS.
THE GREAT Chuck Norris, huh?
The great Chuck Norris.
It's indestructible.
No.
It is
>> Look at that
hairpiece
and cosmetic surgery what it did to his
face face.
You know
Thank you for having us Prime Minister.
Thank you.
>> to see you. You too. I think we can tell
our security people to leave. We don't
need them anymore.
Tell our security people leave we don't
NEED THEM ANYMORE.
I HAVE TO PAUSE IT SO I DON'T GET
SO WE DON'T GET FLAGGED.
YEAH, he's got a hairpiece
and cosmetic surgery.
The guy was one of the most overrated
martial artist and he was boring and he
was a terrible actor.
He was. He sucked.
Go watch his fight scenes now. Go watch
them. Now that you're not a kid, you're
like, "Man, dude." Sloppy, slow,
terrible actor,
tasteless, man.
Bruce Lee they got rid of because he was
Chinese. This guy is a white dude and
they made him a superstar.
Is that not ironic?
Oh gosh, it's been I've been looking
forward to this.
>> Thanks for all the support. I'll believe
me, you'll always have my support. Thank
you for all your support. I'll believe
me, you'll always have my support.
You'll always have my support.
Look at this. It's You know
Yeah, when all that was coming down, you
know, I didn't know what to do cuz my
wife says, "I know what to do. I'm
calling over there." So she's she's
she's very aggressive in that respect.
>> Thank you. Yeah.
>> Thank you. All right. These are
our friends. This is Larry.
security people.
Ooh, you Chuck Norris fan girls are
getting upset, aren't you? But when he
talks about Bruce Lee after Bruce Lee
died, that's okay.
When he tries to make it like he's a
fighter, Bruce Lee's not a fighter,
that's okay. It's okay to slander about
a dead man. You fake effeminate dogs,
sons of the [__] Babylon. Yeah.
Your mother is the [__] of Babylon cuz
you are bastards of Satan. You're not
Christians.
When you are fake
and use a standard that you don't apply
to yourselves. So, it's okay when they
talk about dead people like Bruce Lee.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
You filthy lowlifes. detail And this is
Kyle. It's good to see you. the Prime
Minister. So, we can uh we can get rid
of everyone.
Tell them to clear the building. They
can go. That's fine.
Okay. Now,
let's now go into some Chuck Norris
facts. He lied about his testimony.
Lied about his record. He wasn't this
great martial artist. And by the way,
here,
when
Rickson Gracie's asked, "How good was
Chuck Norris at jiu-jitsu?"
Okay. Look here. And he this just came
out the other day.
How good was he? Listen to this.
And I want to bring you receipts from
martial artists that competed with Chuck
Norris.
All right?
Look. How good is he? Listen to
Rickson Gracie who's considered perhaps
the greatest jiu-jitsu fighter in the
world. He was better than all his
brothers and he was undefeated.
Okay?
Watch here.
How good is he? Listen.
He's good enough.
Listen. He don't have in his in his
lifetime he cannot be great in many
things.
And he learns jiu-jitsu after some he's
not too young, so
he he learn a lot, he train a lot, he
loves, he practice,
but he never get in a level of compete
competitors level. Hear it? He never got
on a competitor's level. He was never
that good.
Good enough.
Yeah, we got it.
Loser, we got it, Divine Mercy. You're a
loser.
So, because he was a nice guy
and he helped people out financially
and he helped the Gracies financially
they're not going to say anything bad.
Oh, he's a great martial artist. But
notice, he can't lie.
Wait, how good was he? Listen.
He's good enough.
He's laughing.
>> have in his life in his lifetime he
cannot be great in many things.
And he learned Jiu-Jitsu after some he's
not too young, so
he he learned a lot, he trained a lot,
he loves, he practices
but he never get in the level of compete
competitors level.
Hear it?
And he loves
he loves Chuck Norris cuz Chuck Norris
helped his family financially. And point
of fact Chuck Norris got choked out by
their father. When he went to Brazil,
him and Bob Wall went there
and then their father, Helio, said,
"Let's go on the mat." And within
seconds Chuck Norris was out. He woke
up. Their father had choked him out
like a ragdoll showing he's nothing.
He's overrated.
You must really suck to be choked out in
seconds. And I'm not a martial artist,
Chuck Norris would have killed me.
But you've made him into something he's
not.
So, is Rickson Gracie hating on Chuck
Norris?
Is Rickson Gracie lying? He's good
enough, never competitive level.
But if you're Chuck Norris, he thinks
that he was great.